Jordan Klepper here it's almost
Thanksgiving our most peaceful American
holiday but in our current political
climate Thanksgiving with family can be
a bit tough
Thanksgiving is by far the most
appropriate time to change another
person's deeply held core beliefs this
is the time to pounce find the weakness
that lies in familial bonds and
tryptophan and finally win the day
here's some tips put the big game on
every channel make sure everyone stands
for the anthem regardless of age or
joint health if you trigger them early
and often they'll weaken over time take
every opportunity inject their small
talk with your big talk hey cousin
Sheila your baby's first steps
chemtrails are real you'll know they're
weakening if they say they don't want to
talk politics let's just enjoy the meal
this this is your moment throw the
entire pumpkin pie at the wall and shout
politics or the meal every family has
that uncle who ruins every holiday hi
in that holiday uncle you in that
holiday uncle we in that holiday on them
Happy Thanksgiving
[Music]